this is the galleria vittorio emanuele
the second in milan a 19th century
arcade with a beautiful glass roof for
expo 2015 the upper stories are open to
the public for the first time they offer
a whole new view of Milan Cathedral and
Swiss photographer Elena kung is taking
advantage of that she'd never seen the
two buildings before now she's captured
them in large format pictures essence
the guns of blood sis funk that first of
all it's fantastic to be the whole
square from above I especially like the
galleria vittorio emanuele and the
cathedral in the background well that
and then I can go for a stroll uphill
all the way over to the cupola of the
Vittorio Emanuele vittorio emanuele the
gangway on the roof of the arcade is
named the High Line from here the glass
and steel construction can be examined
up close and the cathedral next door can
be seen from a new perspective
down below in front of the cathedral
italian artist michelangelo pistoletto
has set up a temporary installation it
symbolizes a possible and desirable
harmony between nature and technology
next door in the Palazzo really they're
presenting the largest Leonardo da Vinci
exhibition in Italy's history 120
paintings and drawings traced the
artistic development of this Renaissance
genius one of the highlights is da
Vinci's famous vitruvian man a study of
the ideal proportions of the human body
and here's a freshly restored loan from
the Louvre in Paris llamo but for the
first time we can see the bed fianya
cleaned and with the original flesh
tones and with this extraordinary
plasticity plastic cheetah k dean furman
we put it facing a sculpture by da
Vinci's teacher by rocio to show how
Leonardo achieved the three
dimensionality of a sculpture on a flat
surface defect otra dimensión our
laziness cultura the curators had
machines built to match Leonardo's
construction drawings
the Prada foundation opened its Art
Museum and southern Milan just in time
for the expo the exhibition serial
classics shows how sculptures have
frequently been copied and reproduced
from the days of antiquity on the former
factory grounds is a 1950's style
library and cafe designed by us film
director Wes Anderson Patrizio Bertelli
who established the foundation with his
wife fashion designer Miuccia Prada our
modern-day patrons of the Arts no spots
you okay this is a center that can be
many things at one time a museum or a
gallery depending on how we set up the
program whatever we wanted a venue
that's not always used in the same way
omoge a dynamic we wanted something
that's versatile at the temple sees the
museum's trademark is the former factory
tower world-famous architect Rem
Koolhaas had it completely covered in
gold leaf the theme of the grounds is
the interplay between new structures and
historical buildings the elements of the
courtyard the street are equally
important almost as the space is
dedicated to exhibition so that it's not
only an art institution but also a piece
of also campus and also can really part
of the city almost a miniature City
back in downtown Milan the city's Harbor
la darsana built in da Vinci's time
languished in neglect for more than 25
years but in the run-up to the expo it
was thoroughly restored now it's turned
into a popular gathering place for Milan
residents and tourists alike
you